oh thanks I just want to say that I
would never ever make this for myself
but I really hope he likes it hi how are
you doing oh good okay cool so if you
can have any dish in the world today
what would you have it dragon fire
chicken with pizza stuffed inside what
is that supposed to mean what does
dragon fire supposed to mean
maybe you could draw it for me and help
me help me out a little
here's that she can put it okay is it
just like a regular chicken flavor does
it have is it garlicky is it spicy spicy
it's spicy you like spicy good well okay
what's spicy to a kid like how much can
he handle um you know I don't want to go
too overboard so I'm just gonna you know
tiptoe into spice a territory oh that's
a big chicken let's talk about the pizza
here's the pizza what toppings do like
pack the peppers doesn't have pepperoni
yes yes
okay okay green and red peppers
pepperoni pizza here's the dragon
that's a drop you know there's a full-on
dragon inside of this chicken what I
mean I I don't know what I'm gonna do
and you said that there's dragon flames
what do dragon flames taste like it
tastes like olives
I would assume dragon fire could be like
ketchup or you know something like red
and saucy and he said it tastes like
olives okay this is really hopeful thank
you so much I mean I'm gonna try my best
do you believe in me yes yes okay that's
the vote of confidence I made my plan
we'll see how it goes I'm going to pound
a chicken breast really thin put a bunch
of spices on it not too spicy and then
fill it with marinara mozzarella peppers
pepperoni roll it up and then I'm gonna
take puff pastry and brush it with
tapenade and then I'm gonna put the
chicken inside of the puff pastry and
wrap it up that way you have some of the
like dough component of what pizza could
be and it's gonna hold it all together
so it's not gonna be like this giant
mess I don't know if that's really gonna
work but well okay so can start with
just a tiny bit of cayenne kinds pretty
aggressive and Jackson the six so don't
get too crazy some Italian seasoning
paprika maybe that's like a nod to fire
and flames two two teaspoons of salt a
little pepper so he wanted red and green
peppers there's not going to be that
much room for filling so I don't think
we need that much I was thinking that
the pepperoni should be layered but
maybe it should be chopped
any one full pepperoni okay so now we're
gonna pound the chicken breast I'm gonna
wash my hands
and just gonna go for it so I feel like
pounding the chicken breast really thin
is just gonna give more options for
filling it it might not be what he
intended but you know artistic what
thank you is a liability and it was like
yeah but taking a creative Liberty so
spiced chicken I'm gonna wash my hands
can sorry I forgot that the oven needs
to be preheated so just do that let me
just just now I'm gonna layer some
mozzarella on top of this herbage
chicken I think a layer of pepperoni he
seemed really enthusiastic about the
peppers like this feels like a lot to me
but say oh and another layer of cheese
kids love cheese it's Stacy okay so okay
so this giant chicken Mound
okay this cheese clearly needs to
believe I said we have this like weird
chicken log that we're gonna chill in
the refrigerator for a little bit my
work here is done
I forgot marinara sauce oh no it's like
kind of crucial to pizza should I unwrap
it what should I do okay okay back again
okay oh boy this is like what am i doing
okay back to the fridge so now that the
chicken is chilling for a bit I'm gonna
roll out the puff pastry and see if I
can make some puff pastry flames does
this look like a flame I don't know it
looks like a sad turkey hand like maybe
it needs some more like flames on flames
like layers
you know actually if you hold this
upside down it could almost look like
this flame I feel like the bone is more
successful than the fire it
unfortunately does look like a dog bone
I feel like he could have you know he
could have tried to do something similar
now I'm going to brush the puff pastry
with olive tapenade
since dragon flames taste like olive of
course with beef wellington you have a
layer of like mince mushrooms called
duxelle so maybe the tapenade won't be
that bad so I'm just gonna fold it up
like a little present okay so it turns
out that this is smaller than I
anticipated so maybe there's only room
for one flame I think the flames can
overlap it looks like a dragon egg hey
that's a really good start so I'm gonna
brush it in egg wash spring clean it
with flaky sea salt because you know I
doubt Jackson will care but I just feel
like it'll make it a little nicer and in
the oven it gets the bones a little tart
so this needs some more time but I need
to remove this so I don't feed him a
totally this is not my best planning but
it actually looks better than I
anticipated I feel like the flames
actually really came to life in baking
it did explode a bit on the bottom but
he's not gonna see that and I know it
didn't call for parsley but I just can't
help myself
Jaxon's about to eat this weird creation
I don't know if he was expecting this
kind of interpretation but I think it
looks good and I hope the flavors work
together crossing my fingers are you
ready to me okay so everything is inside
so the chicken and pizza stuff is all
inside of here what do you think so far
[Music]
you wanna try it yesterday
whoa so there's the chicken and inside
there's pepperoni and cheese and peppers
there's olives on the outside of it
because that's what you said dragon
flames taste like okay ready is it spicy
- spicy - spicy
okay so I'm I'm a little afraid to do
this now but if you have to rate this
dish in emojis here are all your choices
[Music]
accurate you know what that's a that's a
fair assessment which one this one
that's not that bad it kind of tastes
like pizza chicken maybe if it wasn't
spicy it would have been better take
some creative liberties to make sure
this isn't like absolutely repulsive so
[Music]